[Applaudissements]
là
voilà ça vous bouleverse convoyer ces
images à chaque fois j'ai encore du mal
à revoir c'est ça cette vidéo qu'est ce
qui s'est passé là alors on a été
bousculé une première fois du coup j'ai
fait tomber mon portable je me suis
relevé j'ai fait deux mais je me suis
rendu compte que j'ai perdu mon portable
de là j'ai voulu récupérer donc j'ai
demandé un policier de récupérer mon
portable il m'a dit que je pouvais y
aller je ne suis pas senti en insécurité
en récupérer mon portable et de là bas
je le prends et tout de suite d'un jeu
je sens qu'à policiers arrivent commence
à me mettre un coup de matraque
télescopique au niveau du bras oui
heureusement que j'ai eu le réflexe de
monter mon coude parce que sinon je
donnerai plus de prendre directement au
visage
il met en scène un deuxième coup encore
au niveau du plat c'est ça quand je
laisse mon bras de la chp
heureusement qu'on a un qui frôle mais
c'est sur le dernier coup quand j'essaye
de récupérer la deuxième fois 2e pont
portable parce que je t'aime leur faire
tomber
de là je prends le coup au niveau du
crâne
je pars encore donc j'ai encore de dos
il me met un coup de pied c est quand je
pars encore vous voyez à la fin il ya un
ses collègues et elle met sa patte
là il va mettre encore un coup de pied
après j'en suis tue encore et encore il
ya un collègue vous voyez quand je pars
up
il essaye de mettre un croche-patte ah
oui donc là bas je titube un peu je me
rends pas compte tout de suite en fait
que j'ai du sang au début je pensais que
l'équipe lever un petit peu je pensais
que c'était mouillé et là je me vois et
j'entends des gens qui faisaient là du
temps elle a du sens et l'assurance en
estrie mehdi qui arrivent et je le
remercie l'ajustement ils sont tout le
temps là il chaque manifestation
vous êtes traumatisés par ce qui s'est
passé sous choc tout le show mur on
pense qu'on pense que ça arrive qu aux
autres bien sûr c'est ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure pour nous et c'est
vrai qu'on voit ça à chaque fois on
envoie des vidéos comme ça tout le temps
en permanence c'est choquant
à chaque fois qu'on voit des vidéos
comme cela depuis plus d'un an série
continue à aller manifester ou
maintenant vous avez peur vous savez
quand le policier m'a dit clairement
comme ça tu reviendras plus clairement
ça veut dire qu'en gros il veut il
souhaite mettre de la peur pour ne plus
manifester
moi quand il ya de la casse sociale donc
à louis delage et manifester quand sur
cette réforme que je ne trouve pas
forcément bonnes ben oui je manifestais
demain s'il ya une autre
il ya encore d'autres réformes comme
ceux là qui vont arriver oui si j'ai
envie de manifester je vais manifester
c'est pas un policier qui va mettre de
la peur pour ne plus faire les
manifestants tout cas